demain votre cuisine ne ressemblera plus
du tout à celle ci si bien sûr vous
acceptez de vous mettre à la dernière
mode si vous avez beaucoup d'argent et
si vous désirez faire des économies
d'énergie mais aussi de temps à quoi
servirait la technique moderne ça ne
nous évitait pas quelques fatigues
d'abord chez vous et bien il y aura un
ordinateur qui s'occupera de la cuisine
on va donc faire à l'intérieur une
cuisson darroze plus vous appuyez sur le
terme sa température et vous allez
régler 245 degrés température du
thermostat et comme c'est une viande qui
demande à être saisis on va piquer à
l'inter de la viande une sonde est
réglée sur l'appareil
cette sonde alors 40 degrés en aura une
viande saisie 45° n'y en a point et 50°
niang bien qu on va donc prétend affiché
le temps de cuisson de l'appareil 1h50
on démarre le programme le temps des
buts 3-2 début de cuisson s'inscrit
automatiquement le temps de transmission
est calculé aussi par l'ordinateur
après le four l'ordinateur s'occupera
aussi de la machine à laver du lave
vaisselle de la cafetière bref de tous
les appareils électriques domestiques et
vous disposez bien sûr de deux caméras
de télévision qui permettent à la
ménagère tout en étant dans sa cuisine
de pouvoir contrôler l'ensemble de sa
maison si cet ordinateur vous paraît
trop compliqué et bien voilà le brûleur
à gaz qui marche par à-coups vos plats
sont plus faciles à cuire le riz au lait
n'attache plus au fond de la casserole
même si vous le faites mijoter pendant
trois heures et la cuisson des carottes
peut se faire sans eau et sans beurre
tout cela parce que la flamme n'est pas
toujours allume on peut régler avec cinq
secondes à lui mais dix secondes va
secondes
on peut également utiliser ce brûleur
on continue s'il en appui sur la grande
flemme ici
[Musique]